- Any more passengers
for Llanfairpwllgwyngyll-
gogerychwyrndrobwllllantysiliogogogoch?
Anybody?
Nope, anybody for Fan-Merc?
- [Narrator] Plans-clull Llanfair
- Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogery-
chwyrndrobwllllantysiliogogogoch.
- [Narrator] Right.
It's a small town in Northern Wales.
Around 76% of the population
here speaks Welsh.
It's also the longest town name in Europe
with 58 letters.
There are literally four
Ls next to each other.
Right there.
What is with this name?
- Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogerychwyrndrobw-
llllantysiliogogogoch
is not the original name
of the village.
(record scratching)
(sheep bleating)
- You've got to be kidding.
- In the 1860s, the name was
contrived by the local cobbler,
and it was meant to bring
in people and tourists.
- Alun, help us break this name down.
- The name means places
within the village.
You've got the Church Mary,
in the hollow of the white hazel,
near to the rapid whirlpools,
at the Church of Tysilio,
and the red caves.
(laughing)
- [Narrator] Okay, so, let's
say you wanna mail a letter.
Do you have to write the whole
name, Postmaster Jim Evans?
- You could.
But you'd have to write very small.
Or, you could use a shortened version,
which is the first 20 letters.
- [Narrator] If you play for
the local football league,
does the name fit on your jersey,
team manager Steve Smith?
- It does, and it's the longest name
of any football team in the world.
And it just about fits.
- Can you say it after a pint,
pub owner Kevin Bryant?
- I'm sure I can.
Let's see.
(bar patrons chatting)
(belching) Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogery-
chwyrndrobwllllantysiliogogogoch.
- [Narrator] God, you did it.
But,
can you put it in a song?
♫ Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogery
♫ Chwyrndrobwllllantysilio
♫ Gogogoch
- [Narrator] Wow, apparently you can.
Llanfair, Llanfair--
- Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogery-
chwyrndrobwllllantysiliogogogoch.
- [Narrator] It might
be the greatest PR stunt
of the mid-1800s.
I don't know, even of today.
After all, we're here.
Here in (clears throat)
Llanfairpwllgwyngyllgogerychwyrndrobwllllantysiliogogogoch.
I think that's pretty good.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)